salut 22e vidéo denning une énigme par
jour pendant 32 jours à l'intérieur du
défi du mental loeb c'était notre petit
kiff de l'été je vous donne une énigme
par jour mais avant de vous donner la
nouvelle énigme vous donne la réponse
d'hier donc si vous n'avez pas vu la
vidéo d'hier regardez-la d'abord la
réponse à qui a trouvé le moins
d'énigmes c'est albert et dans l'ordre
s'adonner julie naïs david thomas et
albert pas besoin de plus grande
explication si vous vérifiez tout les
prémices que je vous donnais au départ
ça fonctionne et c'est pourquoi on va
passer directement à l'énigme
d'aujourd'hui énigmes 22 oui c'est lady
dernière énigme là c'est une énigme qui
mélange les maths très légère et la
logique
je vous mets au défi de trouver un
nombre à cinq chiffres qui respecte les
contraintes que je vais vous donner le
premier des cinq chiffre doit être la
moitié du second
le 2e chiffre doit être la moitié du
troisième le quatrième chiffres et de
deux de moins que le troisième est de 3
fois le dernier et indices
supplémentaires la somme des cinq
chiffres si on additionnait les cinq
chiffres du nombre
ça ferait 22 celle ci aussi c'est une
énigme que vous pouvez résoudre si vous
mettez ça un papier si vous passez
quelques minutes dessus je suis sûr que
vous pouvez trouver le résultat dès que
vous l'avez trouvée ne l'annoncé pas
dans les commentaires ou dit juste j'ai
trouvé mêlé c'est un petit pouce en
l'air pour qu'on puisse voir le nombre
de personnes qui ont réussi à résoudre
l'énigme
on approche de la fin du mois d'août
donc profiter encore un maximum de l'été
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de
partir voire même de partager cette
vidéo pour partager une énigme de temps
en temps ça fait plaisir puisque le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an donc rendez vous demain à
11 heures parce que demain c'est samedi
ciao
oui